fine yeah oh sorry okay bye babycakes
I love you so are there any boys are
interested in right now or girls well
none of your business when I was your
age I had a crush on Daniel Sanchez oh
I'm so cute
we meet out under the ball this adorable
photo of you I think you were too oh you
don't have to show me that you're so
cute
did you do the fun I think I want to put
it on the Instagram huh don't do that
how do I tell you you just don't don't
come in Hey Baby Cakes come on my phone
right now no it's fine we're just gonna
watch a movie after dinner no you don't
need to talk to her now come on Izzy
little bit you're not actually going out
like this
what it's comfortable can't you be
fashionable for once I used to wear that
exact same outfit so you're wearing what
your unfashionable mother used to wear I
just seriously I'm on the phone I washed
and folded your underwear for you you I
can do that myself good then do it oh
yeah I can come and get you I'm just
chillaxing no never better get the party
started but don't drink and drive
mom there's nothing worse oh you don't
want my scene you know
well how about my dress no you know
you're really starting to look like
you're proud it's so hot today
mm-hmm you have your sunscreen on no I
want to get tan being tan isn't gonna
matter when your stinking mom no no come
on rub it in here we go know what you're
gonna rule my hair yes but you're not
going to get wrinkles and you'll thank
me for it later